look we knew the Steelers we're gonna
face the Jets before Bell signed with
the Jets but it landed so late on the
calendar that it's not nearly as
compelling just think if it would have
been a week 1 or a week 2 type of a game
but Bella's healthy Belle had a great
night last Thursday against the Ravens
and Belle has an opportunity along with
the rest of the Jets to throw a major
wrench into this late season effort by
the Steelers to get to the playoffs and
I think the Steelers even though they
are overmatched in almost every game
they play I think through just sheer
force of Mike Tomlin's will and
personality they'll win the game but
Lady Anne Bell's gonna do everything he
can to screw it up and I won't be
surprised if he does big cat yeah how
mad is Le'Veon Bell that he's playing
against this Steelers defense and not
the Steelers defense that the team had
like a couple years ago when it was the
weakness of the team because this
Steelers defense is one of my favorite
units in all football and it's gonna be
a tough task for Le'Veon Bell on Sunday
I you mentioned Mike Tomlin I like to
write my wrongs when it comes to things
I say that are very very wrong and my
assessment of the entire situation last
year was completely wrong Mike Tomlin
deserves all the credit because it's
pretty clear when you see him what's
happened with Antonio Brown you see that
Le'Veon Bell you know was gone and had
no intention of playing for the Steelers
last year Mike Tomlin keeping that team
together keeping this team together it's
incredible he's my coach of the year I
know he probably won't win because
doesn't have enough wins this year but
Mike Tomlin deserves more credit and I
think there was a lot of people who kind
of myself included who's like hey he's
losing the locker room it's a circus you
got the periscopes and the Facebook
lives and all this noise Mike Tomlin has
kept this organization on track in a
year that thing's like any other
organization Mike and this is a four win
team Mike Tomlin has got them on the
precipice of getting into the playoffs
they're not gonna do anything in the
playoffs but the fact that we're talking
about the playoffs is incredible in a
testament to him as a head coach well
and one of the things we've learned this
year about Antonio Brown there is no way
you're going to get anything out of the
guy if you ever say or do anything that
he doesn't like to hear right he wants
no one telling him
he can't do what he wants to do and I
think the ultimate psychological test
for Mike Tomlin was figuring out how to
best handle Antonio Brown at a time when
he was highly talented and highly
skilled and that's the deal with the
devil that Mike Tomlin did and the fact
that he kept Antonio Brown even though
all the stuff we heard after the fact of
the things that were kept under wraps
the fact that he avoided a full and
complete Antonio Brown meltdown during
all those years together is remarkable
in hindsight because everyone else has
failed to handle Antonio Brown including
the people close to him no one can tell
him anything no one can get it no one
can get him to put his phone down for 10
minutes I mean he's he's his own worst
enemy and Tomlin coached him and
directed him and guided him into a way
that that avoided being a major problem
until the end of last season when it
just all blew up and I think his skills
had gotten to the point where the
Steelers decided it's time to move on
we've dealt with this long enough but
the fact that Tom had kept it from
blowing up before last year in hindsight
is one of the greatest coaching
accomplishments that I can ever remember
yeah and I I like the Steelers in this
game I think the Steelers when you know
their defense the old saying defense
travels duck Hodges I'm a duck guy he
did in fact kill the Steelers last
Sunday and so it's gonna be important
for him to get back on track and he
really doesn't have to do that much
that's the thing he needs to play within
himself he needs to not make the
mistakes that kill them the famous quote
that Mike Tomlin had when he made the
switch from Mason Rudolph to duck Hodges
well duck Hodges hasn't killed us yet it
happened last week so I expect him to
play a clean game and I think the
Steelers are gonna win this game and
we're gonna be in week 17 talking about
them in the playoffs
here's my duck heart just take that you
can steal and act like it was your own
they need to keep playing duck Hodges
because they need to assess which of
these guys can potentially be the
replacement for Roethlisberger at some
point down the road it's not Mason
Rudolph they need to see where duck
Hodges sealing is that's one of the
reasons why he's still playing
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports